especially going through a divorce and
having a kid I had decided I'm going to
be by myself forever and I had just
become okay with that but I've gotten
used to the idea of being alone so not
being alone is so much better when your
brain tries to get you to isolate when
it's not doing well so if you are like
feeling lonely it'll tell you not to
reach out to people and then it becomes
the spiral and you have to override it
and be like okay my brain's giving me
the absolute worst advice go out and
hang out with someone you like even just
go get ice cream it doesn't matter just
do something human beings are much more
social animals than we let ourselves
realize even those of us who are like
fiercely independent